días después del terremoto los
socorristas continúan sacando cuerpos de
los escombros cerca del epicentro de la
tragedia Hay una ciudad que acogía a
miles de refugiados sirios incluyendo
niños que ya han vivido mucho durante la
Guerra y para quienes el trauma Es
evidente
Mohamed de 12 años es de jama en el
centro de Siria y nos lleva a conocer a
su familia sobrevivieron al terremoto
pero su casa ha quedado gravemente
afectada Aunque no es seguro no tiene
nada dónde ir
tengo miedo tengo miedo cada vez que voy
a mi habitación creo que se moverá caerá
y luego hará mucho ruido no soy solo yo
quien tiene miedo mis hermanos también
mi hermana tiene demasiado miedo para
entrar en nuestra casa el techo está
roto y eso también no se asusta
esos niños nunca han conocido momentos
en guerra en Siria y ahora la madre
naturaleza ha atacado el lugar que
habían apropiado como su hogar su
Refugio seguro se ha desplomado en una
noche
el día después del terremoto los niños
estaban luchando psicológicamente pero
se han visto obligados a adaptarse
debido a la guerra en Siria
cada vez que salen también otro
terremoto o una bomba lanzada por
bashara
con millones de necesitados aquí
la situación de seguridad es angustiante
los saqueos son cada vez más comunes y
algunos culpan a los refugiados sirios
la policía nos trató mal yo estaba
tratando de llevar un poco de madera
para calentar a mi familia y me hicieron
tirarla me acusaron de ser un ladrón soy
un ladrón con esta mano herida estaba
ayudando a los turcos me quedé dos días
para ayudarlos mi hijo y yo
Esta es una región donde las comunidades
han coexistido durante siglos pero
incluso antes del terremoto existían
tensiones entre turcos y sirios ahora
para familias como estas hay preguntas
reales sobre qué les depara el futuro